when the masks came down he was asking
questions like do we want to enforce
these policies where is the data to back
this up
when the vaccine mandates came down he
wasn't afraid to say hold on a second
i'm not getting in the way of people's
individual relationships with their
doctors that's not my job if you want to
get vaccinated great if you don't want
to get vaccinated that's up to you so i
saw a guy that wasn't afraid at a very
difficult moment in history to say
i'm going to stand up for people's
individual freedom so when when i hear
things like you know you said he was an
authoritarian and it sounded to me
truthfully like you had a lot of
personality issues with him maybe maybe
you guys just don't get along in the
same way that a lot of people had
personality issues with donald trump and
felt like you know character-wise maybe
he wasn't the guy for the job or the way
he approached the public wasn't the
right guy for the job but honestly
authoritarian or dictator that's the
furthest thing i think of when i think
of dissent is because he was fighting
against those policies you want to talk
to an authoritarian talk to bill de
blasio talk to gavin newsom talk to
people who were telling people you need
to do this or else desantis wasn't doing
that he's not doing that he's doing on
every other policy everywhere everywhere
where is it that you see that i'm
curious everything else from taking
power away from the legislature every
single step of the way what he did with
the maps that was taking power away from
the legislature trying to take power
away from the cabinet from from my own
position um everything he's done to
really strip a lot of power going after
the school boards you know when you talk
about individual freedoms every
individual school board was trying to
make up the decisions of what was best
for their own communities and not only
did he go after the school board members
he then threatened to how was he going
after the school board members like what
saying what well first of all he was
going to remove superintendents if they
had actually done mass mandates he was
going to withhold dollars from each of
the school boards who actually had a
mask mandates in place he actually was
holding back money from our school
districts that were doing was he
preventing people who wanted to wear
masks in those schools from wearing
masks what he was doing was no it was he
though was he if you wanted to wear a
mask till kingdom come for the next was
he saying don't wear a mask or was he
saying if you don't want to wear a mask
you shouldn't be mandated to because
this is not that first that's not what
he did that's not what he did what he
did was he shamed people for wearing
masks he made them feel you're stupid he
actually yelled at our kids who did wear
masks and yells and take that damn thing
off your face
that is not what a governor is supposed
to do a governor if he really truly
cared about freedom he should have let
those kids be the whoever they want
because then that was going their kids
their parents asked them to do that or
they had a conversation look what he's
doing on abortion rights
talking about you just had talked about
you shouldn't be getting in between a
doctor and a personal freedom decision
he just went after it that's a little
bit different though but it well that's
in your portion's a little bit different
because it involves a third person
though you have to acknowledge that
right no i mean
listen i support exceptions for for rape
incest life of the mother we can have
that debate all day long about abortion
but
the reality is that there is another
person involved that's living inside a
woman so that's why he he that that's
why that's not an individual decision
between a woman and her doctor in my
view that's that's a decision between a
woman and her doctor and there's a
conversation can i just ask both of you
guys a question because what i get tired
of
is
whether you're on the the left and
you're calling a desantis or a trump an
authoritarian dictator or whether you're
on the right you do the same thing for
obama or de blasio
aren't we being a little hyperbolic when
we're calling anyone in america today
a dictator authoritarian no no not at
all no i mean listen
how many people get compared to freaking
adolf hitler in america
no that's different but both sides make
that case and it's it to me it's so
hyper first of all you know when you
look at the conversation and i have
studied you know some of these these you
know countries and i have studied the
rise of the nazis what did they do they
went in and they tried to make it more
difficult for people to vote they went
in and they made it more difficult for
people to protest they then went in and
they segregated parts and blamed people
for for things and then they started
banning
books
this is what is happening in florida we
have a list of where where where he's
banning people from protesting in
florida you're not allowed to protest in
florida did you watch the law that
passed two years ago where he's made it
more difficult for people people protest
in florida peacefully all the time
peacefully yes and and you shouldn't be
protesting violently well you should
never be
violently doing that but what he's done
is said if you are protesting like
somebody who's in a car if there's a
protest you can run through them and if
you happen to if a violence happens or
if something happens and breaks out
instead of these protests somebody
everybody around there can be arrested
what it's doing is deterring people from
showing up and actually protesting i
don't see that at all and i don't if
there's violence i mean you have to shut
down a protest as well but they're gonna
rest if i showed up at a peaceful
protest
and violence turned it turned violent in
some capacity everybody there gets you
think ron desantis has on his agenda
right now to stop to try to inhibit
people from peaceful approach i mean
really can you say that i do well
with it clear because because look at
what he's also done he has not said a
single word about january 6th he has not
said a single word about any of the
nazis that have been coming and
protesting on our streets that in
orlando on three separate occasions he
said nothing about the fact that there
is anti-semitism um flyers that are
being passed out in miami he said
nothing about any of these but yet when
black lives matter was out in the
streets that's when those pieces of
legislation came through were they
destroying property no they were not
they were very peaceful protests here in
the state of florida and the fact of the
matter is that is not when the piece of
legislation was filed after january 6th
it was done prior to it and it is deemed
unconstitutional and it is going to get
to the supreme court i'm going to be
honest with you when people look at
issues i mean i understand what you're
saying i hear your perspective i
appreciate your perspective on where
you're coming from but when people look
at issues right now we're in a time
where
people can't get baby formula on the
shelves people can't fill up their car
tanks with gas people can't you know
people can't make a decision in some
places you know what went on in new york
city now the mandates have been lifted
but people were worried about being able
to make a health decision for themselves
and their families without government or
big corporate hands strangling them
every every couple of seconds or forcing
them out of their jobs people are
worried about crime i mean new york city
is destroyed los angeles is destroyed
right now
these that's where the focus is that's
where these dinner table conversations
with if you want to beat someone like
desantis and i assume you do you're
going to have to come in and say
these are the issues where i'm going to
do better than you and that's going to
be really hard because on those issues
florida is rising above all of these
liberal-led states all of them and
people are flooding here for it and for
their businesses for their families for
the safety all of those bullet points
florida check check check that's hard
that's a hard job and i want to know
like how are you going to do that how
are you going to say all these things
going well i'm going to do it better and
here's why so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]